you can only see people down the side
of your screen no no we can't
no we can't no we can't i
can see a few people along the bottom i
can see trish lawrence and robin
charles trish chris and nick i can't see
anything i've got a full page here it
says joint scrutiny committee
the 11th of january 21 and just one
person speaking in the bottom right hand
corner
in the top right of the box if you click
view in the top right of the box if you
move your cursor up
it'll highlight top right of the box
we're actually
we're actually live now chair okay thank
you
welcome everybody to this first meeting
of strata joint uh
scrutiny committee for 2021 i think all
counselors are present and i would also
welcome the uh executive members
um who are joining us from tdc ecc
and ed dc um
and um we are live streaming so
uh uh the meeting has started so
um all participants are taking part
remotely
and uh we are live streaming this on uh
youtube everyone um there will now be a
role call
for confirmation of members of the
committee um
that they are present and when names are
called uh could councillors please
advise so i'm gonna ask trish to take
the road
roll call please okay thanks chad um
german a point of order do you think you
can help me
to get in because i've got my council
ipad on here the only thing that i'm
provided with
and i'm trying to view this meeting on
zoom as i've said to you
ah something's happened now trish's
face has appeared can i i think i can
alter that i think
thank you i can now got everybody thank
you very much
okay thank you trish um yeah okay thank
you
um councillor king a present
councillor twist yep here trish yeah
thank you
councillor hookway president thank you
councillor sparks
oh she's uh sorry that's an apology and
counsellor nuttal
present and yourself chair present yes
thank you thank you uh thank you
um right so just a few announcements as
to how we're um
uh going to conduct uh the meetings so
um could i ask all
counsellors to make sure your
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking
to avoid any background uh noise levels
also could i ask you to keep your points
short and do not interrupt somebody when
they are
speaking um if you wish to speak could
you
raise uh your electronic
hand i think it was blue but i think
it's a different color now is that right
and wait wait to be called um if
um members lose internet contact
connections the meeting will be paused
for a few minutes
to try and allow the member to rejoin
but i mean um we won't it won't be
um upheld indefinitely and obviously
members of strata will try and contact
you to
assist you but if it's an internet con
failure um
on your side there's absolutely nothing
we can do about that
um so um
if um we're not able to reconnect the
within 50 minutes the meeting
um will be adjoined and reconvened at a
later date
if that all the internet um goes down
um for the meeting
so that's basically if trish in the
offices
go i just want to tell you
that this is a scrutiny meeting
and the things that we're scrutinizing
today are going to be going to the
strata joint executive
on the 25th of january and um as i've
indicated we have three members of that
committee who are joining us um to hear
our discussion
um today so in the purpose of scrutiny
is not to make any decisions but
to um discuss issues of concern
so that we can help the executive in
their decision making on the 25th of of
january january um
and um we have i just only
another announcement to make in relation
to item five which is
questions from counsellors we have
received one question
um and i may say this is a very
good question and an excellent example
of good scrutiny
and very pleased to have received this
question from councillor currents
however in view of the nature of
matters to be discussed in answering
that question
we're going to take the answer under
part
two of of the agenda so we won't be
starting that until we stop the live
recording and we can go into closed
session
so before i move on to the agenda items
is that all clear
yes okay thank you thank you chairman
for that counselor clarence
can i just help me again can you remind
me i've got a picture that you can all
see
of a plug and a charging box in my
stream the the
the cameras round the wrong way how do i
get my mug shot onto
an ipad rather than do it i think
there's a simple way you can tell me
isn't that
counselor clarence it's it's lawrence um
there should be a little icon that says
switch camera where you can alternate
your view
from your plug to yourself can you see
that it's probably on the left hand side
of your screen
i've certainly got it on my ipad screen
at the moment yes
thank you
could i also say that at exodus city
council
um we have a gender-neutral policy
therefore
i do not like to be called chairman i
like to be called
chair and um i think if you note that
also for minutes because i know some um
on the minutes um as we come on to i was
referred to as a chairman
okay so it's a matter of protocol okay
sorry sorry chair that was um
yeah sorry that's fine thank you
um right so i'm going to move on to um
item one now which is apologies um i
think we've dealt with apologies have we
are there any others that you haven't
yes chair just um counselor orm
thank you thank you um so now moving to
item two which is the minutes of the
last meeting held on the 8th of
september um
so i'm going to ask members of the
committee if this is a
correct record of that meeting
um does that mean somebody's put their
hand up that noise
no i think that's somebody trying to
join trish i think pete jones has lost
yeah joe i've um i've just let peter
johns into the meeting
thank you okay um
so what i'm going to suggest in view of
this item
is that um i'm going to ask for anybody
who disagrees to put their hand up this
is a correct record
does anybody think this isn't a correct
record
put your hand up now
okay is there any trish i can't see any
no chair there there aren't um are there
any um
any people who wish to abstain
no okay well that motion is passed
unanimously
yeah i'm moving on now to
item three which is declarations of
interest does any member present have an
interest that he which
he or she wishes to declare
okay thank you i'm now going to move on
to item 4 which is
public questions and i'm informed that
there are no members of the public
who've asked questions
at this time and
therefore we move to item five which has
been moved to part two of the agenda
so we're going to move now on to um
agenda item six which is the it
director's report
and our last cit director um lawrence
wicklock to present the report
um and after he's presented the report
um
well we'll take do you want questions
you're going along or at the end
lawrence i'm going to um we're normally
fairly flexible actually
hopefully people can see the screen
again now um
so just with a few slides but happy to
take questions as we go along
or leave them to end really up to you
chair
so so this is a discussion of the
business plan which is going to go to
the um
strata executive um on
the 25th the business plan is actually
in part two along with the answer to
council classes question
this is more of a review of the last
four months since we
had the last joint scrutiny meeting all
right just give you a bit of an update
on what we've been up to
okay okay thank you yeah that's okay
thank you
is that okay good
over here there thank you very much
chair um
uh good afternoon everybody it's
lawrence whitlock here rit director
obviously uh happy new year to everybody
uh very strange times we find ourselves
in but
uh obviously great to have you all on
board this afternoon
um i put together a few slides just to
give you a little bit of an update on
what's been going on over the last three
to four months
um the primary part of this afternoon is
to talk about the strata business plan
which hopefully everybody's had a chance
to
have a have a look at that will be
covered in part two
um but really what i just wanted to
cover off as part of
my report um is really just to talk
about what what's been going on
um we talk about global desktop and
global comms
and obviously that is now so
fundamentally important the way the
authorities all three authorities work
um what has been really a a key priority
of us
is ensuring the stability of that
environment
and ensuring that it remains pretty much
100 available because
without this environment very little of
what the authorities were doing and
their staff being able to work remotely
would be possible
so hence it was really critically
important to us to ensure
these two platforms which um we've spent
five years building
um you know you know it's just so
fundamental so
i'll cover off a little bit on that
later we've got a major project underway
at the moment
which is migrating all the offices over
to a windows 10 environment the windows
7 environment that
has pretty much underpinned everything
that we've done over the last um
you know four to five years that is
going end of life out of support
in the early part of this year so
therefore it's essential that we
completed the migration which is you
know
very much underway and we're making
excellent progress on that
since we had our last meeting there's
been obviously the opening of extra
leisure this was a significant
uh project for strata um and actually
one we
we undertook a fairly short notice uh
was very successful uh obviously it's
very unfortunate that we find ourselves
in a situation where
the leisure centers are now closed again
uh but actually you know fantastic
joint working from strata next to
leisure to get those centers opening
and fully operational from the existing
supplier over to
extra city uh managing that provision
um huge amount of work on the creation
of business grants obviously
as the areas and as devon has moved
via the various tiering levels there's
been different levels of business grants
available we've had businesses opening
some are closing
um a huge amount of work has gone into
supporting all three authorities
in creating the forms to enable those
businesses to access those money
uh that money and i think again
fantastic working from all three
authorities supported by strata
in actually making those forms and those
grants available to
all businesses that need it
keeping the officers working remotely
has been a primary
concern of all of us at strata we've
undertaken some significant projects for
the provision of new
infrastructure particularly new laptops
into team bridge which has been very
successful
to enable the offices of team bridge to
work remotely
that came on top of the work that we
undertook with extra in the latter part
of 2019 and 20
in the early part of 2020 on the
provision of new i.t
to support remote working and also we've
been able to redeploy a lot of the
equipment that was purchased
for black down house for east evan
district council that's actually been
able to be
re-engineered and deployed to offices
who didn't have access to
laptops to enable them to work from home
remotely so
um we've actually seen a significant
transformation
of staff from working in the offices to
working remotely
but it's actually you know proved to be
very successful
um we obviously at the beginning of
2020 uh or 2019 we put forward the
business
plan for last year where we talked about
the savings that we're going to be made
in this year
we also identified additional savings
in the early part of lockdown to see how
we could help the authorities
with additional savings and um uh
chief finance officer dave hudson will
cover this off as part of his report
but as things stand currently it's
looking very favorable that we will
deliver not only our forecasted savings
but the additional savings we
we put forward in the middle of the year
um
there's been a massive um increase in
the demand
of strata services whether that be
incidents as people have worked more
towards home
service requests people needing uh i.t
to help them be able to perform their
tasks
um from business change requests with
things needing to be
actioned very very quickly or also some
projects so
we've seen a significant increase in the
demand and i've got to slide on that in
a bit
um a lot of the work that we do to
create the new business plan it's not
something that's written overnight
it's something that takes three to four
months to work on
the managers the authorities have worked
very very closely this year on creating
the business plan
um to actually look at what were the
real priorities that you have for next
year when we built those into the plan
we've also done uh work around the
restructuring of the document center
we had three document centers across the
three authorities
however what we found over the last um
12 what 10 to 12 months
is the demand for printed material has
dropped significantly
and we've undertaken a review of the
document center printing capability
and we've restructured that document
center team
around the demand not just currently
during covid but also the foreseeable
future as well
as a result of that we can obviously
deliver savings
uh with some changes that we're making
we're also seeing that
just the the amount of paper that's
being used the amount of consumables
that are being used to support printing
has done has reduced significantly
we've also um reduced we've also held
the strata annual conference that's
something i'm really keen on doing
uh we hold it every year this year was
slightly challenging
uh we have 70 about 71 people with
inside strata 72
and anyway i was really important to me
that we held that event we held it
virtually via zoo
hugely successful and i've got a nice
announcement to be able to make
as a result of that conference so that's
really what we've been up to to look at
some specifics i talked about
the core systems global desktop and
global comms
i do what's termed a radar diagram where
i look at the availability of the
platform
um over the last it's just over two
years now it's about 26 months
what is really pleasing to see from the
first of
february 2020 through to um
well it's actually december because
we're just releasing the latest report
um the availability of that platform has
been pretty much nearly 100
which is a significant achievement to
ensure
that those platforms that support the
working of the authorities are available
if we have a look at it at the uh the
sort of the the 12 to
14 months leading up to february last
year we can see that there were some
periods of downtime
uh the center of the circle is 95 um
availability the outer limit of the
circle is 100
availability so whilst we did see some
downtime
during um that sort of that 14-month
period
we were able to make the investments
that were needed
and luckily enough they've actually you
know really
shown the benefit of those investments
and also the availability of the
platform
on the right-hand side um i've actually
got a slide there that shows the
increase in remote working of your users
across the three authorities
and uh period one was really in uh
late march early april where we moved
from
um you know a low level of people
working remotely
to where we are currently which is
period 19
where we actually see a significant
level of resources across all three
authorities
working remotely i think last week at
east devon
we hit approximately 87 percent of east
evan staff who were
accessing the system were working
remotely as opposed to about 13
of staff who were working in the office
so i think this is great that
obviously the guidance that we have from
the government is that
staff work from home the figures that
we're able to show
utilizing global desktop and global
comms is that
staff are doing what the governments are
telling them to do and that that's you
know something i think to be really
proud of
that not only the authorities able to do
it but we're able to deliver the
infrastructure that has enabled us
and enabled your users to work remotely
um i talked about demand and this is
something that
has you know come at uh you know over
the last since february 2020
uh through to march where we saw an
increase but we're actually seeing a 300
increase in the demands on strata over
that period of time
so you know we've gone and what we look
at is the number of
calls that are open at the end of each
month and actually we look at
the number of calls that are open at the
end of each day
and whilst the staff on the service desk
are delivering exactly the same amount
of work that they were doing
uh leading up to covid we've actually
seen that without really any
additional capacity we have seen that
300
increase and a lot of that comes down to
the support of people working remotely
and just the increase that there is in
people needing new laptops needing new
applications
with the business change requests coming
in from the need to stand up new forms
to support the citizens of devon
so whilst obviously i would like to see
that we were still running
a similar level to what we have in
february actually the increa that we've
seen this 300 increase which is a
significant increase in the overall
demands on strata
that have made been made over the last
sort of 10
11 months um but actually what we're
doing now we have brought
two new members on to the strata service
desk team
and they're going to work with us to
significantly look to reduce the number
of incidents and the number of service
requests
down to a much lower level and hopefully
back to where we were in february 2020.
i think whilst we've obviously seen a
300 increase this
actually is the officers of the
authorities
um actually maybe not being able to
perform
their full their full task to the
optimum
because maybe they've had some issues
with it so what's really important
is that actually we get around to
supporting those officers
um and yourself as counselors when
issues arise
so that people aren't finding that their
i.t is causing them issues for look
for a prolonged period of time and i
guess that's one of my concerns is
we measure customer satisfaction i've
got a slide on customer satisfaction
it's really important to me
that all users are satisfied with the
service we're given
um it became very clear sort of through
september
and october and into november that the
users were starting to
uh we were seeing a slight drop in
customer satisfaction from the level
that it's normally at
and that meant that we needed to look at
how do we address that and the key thing
was
bringing additional resources in because
we actually have a very low level of
sickness across strata
and it was clear that we had reached
maximum capacity
uh yet demand was out completely
outstripping the capacity that we had so
we spoke to the board and we made the
decision uh
and we bought those staff in uh and you
know they joined on the 1st of july 2nd
of january
we're really hopeful that we can start
to uh clear some of the backlog
that is built up just to give you a
little bit of an indication here i
talked about the overall demand
i did a snapshot on the 31st of march of
incidents uh business change requests
and service requests and compared them
to where they were on the 7th of january
if we look at instance for example there
was 118 open
incidents on the 31st of march which is
about time
uh kovid really started to kick in in
this country
as of the 7th of january we had 434 open
incidents i think it was earlier on this
morning we're already up to about 487
open
incidents um likewise for service
request it was 249.
that is all that has almost doubled to
437.
so we're seeing that significant level
of demand
um and it's essential it's an imperative
that we actually work to reduce those
numbers down to a much more reasonable
number
uh what what i can say is the strata
staff who are responsible for delivering
this
have worked tirelessly to actually get
you know to clear down calls when they
come in and to support the officers and
the councillors
i talked about customer satisfaction we
measure customer satisfaction on a
monthly basis as part of our
performance reporting process which is
actually in the monthly report
um or the report that i've sent you
previously
as part of the minutes um you can see
there that you know we had
in uh october and november there was
this drop to
16.8 and 17.1 which is a
combined score across the four metrics
and it's out of a maximum of 20
but it was good to see in december that
actually that score had started to
increase again
uh back to the level that we like to see
about the sea which is sort of circa the
the 19 which is a great level for
customer satisfaction
um one of the things that has been
really important that we've seen
about uh two years ago following
a lot of conversations with the
authorities with the officers and with
joint scrutiny and joint exec
we made a decision to bring a training
resource into strata to actually help
officers councillors uh with the it um
i think that investment has really paid
off
in that we've hopefully been able to
support officers working remotely
we're running a number of training
sessions on a monthly basis to help
people really optimize the it
that they have and clive newton who i
think probably most of you
know now has has worked tirelessly
really to support
the officers trying to get to terms with
this remote way of working because it's
not like being in the office
you know you can't necessarily turn to
your neighbor and ask them how to do
something
you've really got to you know access
that training
uh that we're able to deliver and that
help and support but also we're running
a number of sessions now really helping
people
understand how zoom works understand how
skype for business works
and understand how those applications
that really underpin everything we do on
a daily basis work
and how people can actually make maximum
usage of those
we also made a decision last year that
we would implement a much more
strategic view to uh project management
and we introduced an it solutions
delivery team
uh what we're now able to see is a much
more uh
real-time view of where we are with
projects
this view here gives you a view of where
we are with projects and the great thing
is we're seeing a lot of projects around
that implementation phase
you know we we previously you know
we couldn't necessarily see what was in
the business case phase where what was
opening what was in the procurement
phase
and what was being implemented but the
work through pete jones and his team
have done
have really enabled us to to get that
real live
view of the projects we can see the
project split by authorities
so the graph on the right hand side so
it shows that
at team bridge for example at the moment
there's 28
of strata's work is dedicated to
actually delivering those live
projects of team bridge at um
exeter it's 31 34 and at eastern about
31
and there's about seven strata projects
that are underway at the moment
um that are things like the windows 10
migration
so again great that we've got this view
we're using the
project methodology that david circum
arranged or organized and wrote and
that's really underpinning what we're
doing now
in moving things through this process
and given us a much more real-time view
the other great thing that we can
actually do with that project
methodology
is report to the authorities where all
their projects are
we've got portals available now so that
people can actually see where their
projects are where their business change
requests are
and this really gives that view to how
work is being scheduled and when things
are going to be delivered
i mentioned earlier on about our annual
conference it's something we pride
ourselves
in it's our only chance to get everybody
together once a year
what we do we we ran that in a virtual
world we normally
run it at the ram in exeter um but
that's all about celebrating success we
have a lot of unsung heroes with inside
strata
you know they get on they do their job
day in day out we celebrate their
success we acknowledge the contribution
they make
we update all the strata teams that
whilst we aim not to work in silos there
are times that our teams work very much
in their individual teams
this gives us a chance to talk about
what's been going on
uh we review the year what we've
achieved what we haven't achieved how
we've achieved against the business plan
we also recognize the outstanding
performance of maybe
one or two members of staff but this is
really what's
important to all strata staff and also
what we like to do
we like to support charities as well we
think that's really important with
inside strata
and this year through the work that we
did at the annual conference
uh we've actually uh been able to make a
significant contribution
and this is donations from strata staff
this isn't coming out stratus
profit this is actually contributions
from strata staff
to the children's hospice south west and
the alzheimer's society
really humbled by you know the work that
strata staff did
in uh making contributions and what
we've also done is supported the
hollington food bank as well
through contributions from strata to
that as well so an absolutely admirable
performance um from strata staff and it
shows that we
like to work as a team and support those
less fortunate as ourselves
so really the next four months is going
to be about you know completing the
migration to windows 10 without that
there's a lot of things we won't be able
to do that we've included in the
business plan so again we've got to
complete that work
um we're looking at deploying a
microsoft teams pilot
a move to a wider scale microsoft teams
deployment
that is certainly something that we we
probably have no choice in doing because
it's the way the market's going and it's
the way microsoft are going
um we're in the process of renegotiating
the microsoft
contract that is probably the single
largest contract that we have
as strata and as the authorities have we
have to ensure
that we deliver you a a value for money
contract
that actually delivers you the um the
the technology that you need
not just for now but also for three
years time as well
so that's really important to us over
the next four months
um the delivery of the savings it's
imperative that we make our contribution
to the savings that not only we
committed to as part of last year's
business plan
but also in that accelerated savings
plan that we put forward
we obviously look to the work of joint
scrutiny and the joint exec to sign off
the business plan that we put forward
that really informs our thinking for
next year we obviously know the
importance
of supporting the officers to work
remotely and we'll carry on working
tirelessly to do that
but also we need to ensure that those
systems that you know we
we pride ourselves on that underpin what
we do
actually you know carry on being
available 100
of the time to those officers to enable
you to carry on doing the work
that you have to do as as counselors and
as the officers day in day out to
support your citizens
and i think that that was me done has
anybody got any questions on any of that
right thank you very much for that and
um
i'd like to say a big thank you to the
staff um
for um what came out of the staff
conference and
just just underpins just how how good it
is when you can work in a team
a large team you know is is a great
place to be
thank you i haven't got any members with
their hands up at the moment
i can't believe you don't have any
questions so all of us got a question
all right counselor oliver over to you
sorry are you putting yo can i ask you
to use the um
hands up thing on there yes
i haven't been able to find it i updated
the latest software yesterday
and it's not on participants like it
used to be there's uh
three three i know mark
has moved there's three dots
ah mark devin helpfully sent an update
but i haven't got that with me but i
found
i have lost myself i'm just gonna i'm
wasting your time i could learn to do
this
another time okay uh it isn't coming up
with the three dots
okay i will learn how to do it um
however yeah i i've had a very very good
service from strata
um and i think mike newton must possibly
be the most patient man in the entire
universe however i would say
that um lawrence referred to new laptops
going out to
some of the exeter city council and in
terms of the members
they went to the executive but they
didn't go to the 29 backbenchers
um i was in the position where i had a
very old ipad
when i first became a counselor and that
was why it got to the point where i was
spending more time with mike newton than
my husband
and eventually i got a new ipad because
i needed to
access microsoft teams as part of my
role
from that moment i haven't needed to
speak to mike so
i know that there are other back venture
councillors on exeter city council
struggling with old ipads that take
forever to load up
having the new ipad meant i could do my
work in half the time
and also it meant i didn't need to take
all this time of strata staff
so i know that we're thinking about what
we can afford and what we do
but i think it would save a lot of
strata time
if um as many people as possible had the
best equipment possible
lawrence you want to answer to that yes
more than happy to cover that uh
obviously
this is a capital investment um needed
in the it so new ipads etc
um the extra city council ipads
are old now they're i think between five
and eight years old
um we all know technology changes on a
on a
you know monthly basis and so we find it
you know
it's probably and i did speak to
democratic services recently and i know
they're
looking at what their plans are for the
provision of counsellor i t
um so i do believe you know there are
plans afoot
i can't say what's going to happen
because this doesn't come out of strata
budget this comes out of the authority's
budget
so whereas obviously tdc and
e-7 already have uh fairly modern
ipads because they were only deployed in
2019
obviously the extra ones are
significantly
older um and may well benefit from being
upgraded
um but i'd obviously have to defer that
to
budget holders with inside exeter
lawrence i've got
dave hodgson with his hands up so dave
are you wanting to
um answer that question or is it
indeed yeah yes i i i'll help lawrence
um thank you rather than ask him
something else
uh so yeah council of oliver um
lomas is absolutely right it's uh it's
an extra city council
matter we we would have to fund new
ipads
um i i suggest that that
uh if if you feel strongly you should be
raising it with with your executive
uh probably through councillor pearson
um
with just the reminder of what i said
last wednesday
in the financial briefing to members
so it has to be balanced against um
other priorities if we want to fund this
we have to stop doing something else
um but i do take your point and think
it's it's a valid point
and something that should you know can
be considered alongside everything else
if i may just come in before i'm sure
other officers and other counselors
won't want to ask this question
um but if we migrate to office 365
will um exeter's ipads still
operate because they're an apple
platform as opposed to a microsoft
platform i mean is that going to be an
issue
i probably the best thing to do adrian
are you i believe you're on the call
adrian smith who's our head of
infrastructure
adrian do you think you could answer
that question yes i
yeah i can answer that yeah so yes um we
just reconfigured them to point to
office 365 um they'll carry on and
you'll receive your email as you do now
okay right thank you all right thank you
i've got i in
i'm i i couldn't see which one of you
asked it first i'm going to ask
councillor twist to go first
and then charles natal and um
councillor clarence after that thank you
well it's very kind good afternoon um
everybody i was gonna just amplify the
fact um
actually made by dave hodgson which is
something i raised that
e7 right at the start of our journey on
the new ipads where i
personally objected to spending it
worked out i think
in total about 900 quid per seat or per
person
on an ipad so i actually still operate
perfectly happily um my
strata east evan district council work
on on my own kit
and it sounds a bit like a cat would
have but it's in what's called a sun
sun box environment where um it's still
perfectly secure
and okay so you don't have to have it
all or seeing all
all dancing new ipad to operate and
access the services but questions um
actually relate i i would guess lawrence
and this may be more
for part b but i don't think it is these
are just a
a general question to put out there
because of of of what's happened in in
in the last
year the likes of microsoft and
amazon and zoom and google and all those
big players are going to be going yahoo
we can we'll not go who but
um yeah we can now screw people
on on the amount we charge them in terms
of the licenses and you know and i know
very well
that microsoft in seattle will be
charging down to the accountants and
working out how much they think the
market is going to take
because we haven't got a choice but to
pay it will be their their view
so the question is going to be do we
have any
indication of the kind of percentages
before any discounts or or whatever that
we might be able to negotiate
which is which is a question for part b
that they're
they are actively seeking now um and
that kind of relates to chris clarence's
question as well
um how we can offset that if there's no
way
that we can resist the increases
at least in part can we offset that
elsewhere with
other fees that we're being charged as
other other licenses
by different vendors and um
is that likely to impact on savings
that are returned to the partners in
other words
you know this year we get x amounts um
back in hundreds of thousands of pounds
of benefit which is for taxpayers
um is that likely to be hit by one of
our major suppliers
deciding that they're going to screw us
for their fees
um i'm more than happy to cover that off
it is something that challenges
us with inside the strata management
team uh certainly on a on a daily
um and monthly basis um it's something
that i've been very impressed with all
the managers with inside strata
their level of financial diligence
uh and their desire to do the best
possible
um deal for the authorities um
you know we we did have one supplier um
who uh just before christmas had
basically increase their price from
45 000 pounds a year for their product
um their revised price was 740
000 pounds for their product um you can
imagine the incredibly difficult
conversations we had to have
with that supplier whilst we knew that
the price would go up we certainly were
not expecting a price to go up
by that significant amount because that
literally took away
all the savings that we were going to be
able to deliver you
through through 2020 and 2021
um but actually a huge amount of work
went into working with that supplier
literally every quote they sent us we
sent it back in their direction
and i think it was about one day or two
days before christmas
uh we actually negotiated the deal to
carry on as we were doing with their
technology
uh only a very slight increase from what
we were paying currently
so you know we know microsoft
um are going to be putting their prices
up they're changing their model
for their delivery of services microsoft
are very geared about moving to the
cloud
we have a very on-premise based
microsoft delivery model
when we negotiated the contract three
years ago with microsoft we were able to
get a 54
discount off their list price by
delivering on-prem
uh but then about a week after our deal
they changed it so that discount level
was actually removed
so um had we renewed in april
2018 our price would have been about
300 000 pounds a year more so luckily
our deal expired on the 31st of march
so therefore when we are now just
entering the
april renewal we knew that we weren't
going to get the 54
discount so that would have pushed our
microsoft price up
significantly if i'm not mistaken it
would have gone from about
350 000 pound a year to just over 800
000 pound a year with microsoft
however we're looking uh or we've gone
through the renewal process with
microsoft
we're looking to deploy office 365
which moves it to a cloud type
model for the delivery microsoft product
that enables us still to benefit from a
considerable level of discount
so whilst the price will go up because
we as you said counselor twist we all
know microsoft are a money-making
machine and they do very very well at it
um we're not exposed to the level of
increase we would have been
had we chosen to carry on with a on-prem
based delivery
model so that's delivering microsoft out
of our own data centers
we will now be delivering the office 365
environment
not just to councillors but also to the
offices of the authorities as well
adrian you're there you've been doing a
lot of work on this
anything you'd want to add to this
no i think you've covered it quite well
i think the one thing i will say is that
the
specifically with microsoft which is our
largest contract
uh those prices are negotiated centrally
by government
and then set we don't negotiate those
directly with them so
we have to sign up to what's called the
digital transformation act which is a
centrally negotiated
price framework but we have built that
cost into
next year's business case as we're
already aware of
what the increases are so as it stands
we aren't asking
for any money or predicting to reduce
any savings but
going forward you know we're expecting
more suppliers to move to the
subscription-based revenue
licensing model and then move away from
the traditional capex
software purchases up front
but we can only only come back with that
information as and when we have it
and a lot of the time they won't enter
or we won't give you pricing
until maybe three months before your
renewals due
so whilst we obviously work to try and
include in the business plan
the the knowns what we can't necessarily
do
is actually give the full details of the
unknowns because maybe
they won't be knowing until much closer
to the actual date of the renewal
but obviously we do what we can we try
and build in
any increases into our business plan or
otherwise we caveat the business plan
with comments that actually talk through
you know
where we know there might be a price
increase um
microsoft is probably one of those key
ones because it is such a significant
element of the overall budget
thank you i've got councillor nuttel
next uh thank you chip lawrence thank
you very much for your presentation it
was
very interesting as indeed was the
report which i've been able to read
beforehand thank you just a quick
question about the document center
yes you mentioned the possibility of
savings presumably
paper publishing is is has reduced
significantly
we've got you know 10 full-time
equivalents i think in the document
center we've got a designer and so on
just wondering the extent to which you
can see that as an area for
for maximizing savings um
martin milne's with us martin runs the
document center he headed up the
restructuring uh i'm more than happy to
cover that off myself but martin
would would you like to pass comment
you're the you've got all the experience
and the knowledge
on document centers and print um would
you like to cover that
question off for me yeah i'm happy to um
i think one of the things that needs to
be aware of the document center don't
just do printing i think
we're now really just one person
part-time doing printing
the rest of the team handle post
almost all the posts coming into team
bridge and east devon is now scanned
at the point of entry and distributed
that way
i think that's where most of the team
time goes now is handling
whether it's deliveries or post items
coming in so the savings are coming back
in terms of we'll see lower lease costs
um
lower staff costs and lower consumable
costs going forward
thank you thank you um
did you want to say anything else no
i've got council of clarence next
uh through you chair if i may
the councillor uh oliver i believe was
referring to
somebody called uh mike newton does she
mean clive newton
yes lynch
whether it was somebody i didn't know
about or something like that
that's all it was clyde good he's
excellent chapman
you you've got a brilliant person there
on your team well done we're very lucky
thank you councillor clarence
thank you um i have got um
mike um sorry dave hudson did you have
you put your hand down now
or is it something you want no okay um
counselor king
thanks chair um can i ask two questions
yes please do first one um
i'm most interested in the automation
and the productivity arising from the
printed document versus online digital
document
etc and
on the one hand at eastwood district
council today we had a meeting where
the topic was how to automate billing
how to and the major saving was of
course um postage
uh one then bumped into such matters as
um if you go away from posted
documents to an established address of
the resident
then such document is so often used as
proof of identity
or for accessing financial products or
what have you
and if you sent by email a pdf
that could be passed around etc and it
could be edited perhaps
so there are security issues um and
there are also
um the the matter of go
going online for the resident um
this this project i think from the eddc
end
i've sort of noticed that there's a
tremendous get up and go to
to make a headway on this but of course
we're
bumping into um the pressures put on
strata from
the covered ever-changing uh grants
and the existing uh requirements for
working from home etc so to what extent
um are our sort of the more go-ahead
uh efficiency projects which will have a
big impact on
the parlor state of the council finances
to what extent are those be having to be
having to be
relegated and to what extent can we hope
to get
some some progress on these uh what are
essentially corporate priorities
um so um what we've
tried to do as part of the new business
plan is to look at a number of
metrics now what we've what we have also
done over the last three years is move
away
from strata deciding on our work
priority
for it to be actually driven by the
authorities so
we felt that was really important that
we have a limited amount of resource
and i'm sure you don't want me to go and
recruit another 20 or 30 people there's
no money there
so therefore each of the three
authorities we have what's termed either
a project review board
or a it requirements board um where we
actually
go through each of the projects and each
of the um
requirements and the authorities then
prioritize that workload
um and then obviously they direct strata
accordingly to deliver
what it is that the authorities want
rather than it
is what starts to think the authorities
want which is the wrong way of doing it
um so we'll assume uh and david circa
you might want to come in here if that's
okay
um but you run that process i thought it
works really efficiently
could you maybe pass comment about this
david is that okay
yeah absolutely thank you um so the
the transformation projects uh have um
have naturally taken a little bit of a
hit whilst
the transformation team uh which sits
under me
has been focusing a lot of their time on
producing the
the kobe grant forms and all their
different flavors as they've
they've cropped up during the year and
there's still some
significant work left to do on those
with the various iterations
i think what's really important to make
clear as well though
is that um it's not just strata
that's obviously been impacted on this
the service areas themselves have been
significantly impacted
with their work schedules having to be
moved
and kind of redirected to where they're
needed
and as a result of that a lot of the the
transformation projects
um have not only suffered because of the
lack of strata resource because we've
been
working on covid but also the the number
of um
services that haven't been able to to
kind of support those projects because
they've been focusing on the day-to-day
as well
so it's there's kind of a double whammy
um
so that hopefully is something that
we'll we'll start to see
um lesson as we get the the rest of the
the covered forms
completed um having said that we have
still delivered
um and we we still are continuing to
deliver some significant improvements in
terms of
um transformation uh projects for
the service areas so for example um
the council tax reduction scheme has uh
in east devon and team bridge have had
brand new forms
um produced for those which has enabled
a far
slicker end-to-end process for
processing
um council tax changes um and there's
been
numerous other um projects which we've
been able to progress but just not quite
as much as we'd hoped
because of the the focus on cobit forms
i've got no um other counselor
indicating
um but can i just come back on that mike
um
was it isn't firm step is it firm steps
supposed to be
um about billing and wasn't that one of
the questions that
um he asked which i don't think's been
addressed perhaps you could explain that
okay yeah absolutely so firm step is our
kind of customer platform
which we're fortunate that all three
authorities use
so firmstep enables us to
produce quite sophisticated online forms
there's also a workflow element to it so
that we can automate those processes
um one of the big elements of firmstep
is a customer account so this kind of
brink comes in
um and raises the issue of security
so there's um whilst
anyone can actually sign up for a firm
step account what we can do
is is authorize
and validate that customer once they've
got
their account set up which is unique to
them we can then start
transacting with those customers in a
bit more of a secure way
so one of the things we've done for
team bridge for example and we're
working on it for exeter and east devon
is to be able to link their firmstep
account with other
uh council portals such as the council
tax
portal so from a single point of entry
the customer can view all their billing
information all their forms or their
documents all within the the um
the council tax system benefit system
and that's
that's done in a very secure way
so there's a lot of work which we're
doing in order to be able to really
improve the efficiency and streamline
not only for customers but also for the
staff that are working with the
authority as well
so whether that's sending out emails
instead of making telephone calls
sending out text messages reminders so
that
customers know exactly where
their call is their processes in in
along that stream
um integrating with mobile devices for
officers so rather than having officers
come back into the office to collect
their work and go out
you know we've we've got a seamless
end-to-end kind of process
where a customer can report something it
can be
locked within that particular back
office system via firm step
it gets pushed out to a mobile device
the officer does the fulfillment on that
device
and then that goes back into firm step
back into the back office system and the
customers notified
and that's really the the kind of the
the end game that's what we're working
for
is to really minimize any duplication of
effort
you know manually typing updates into
systems
we really are trying to focus on making
sure that the
the whole process is as seamless as
possible from an end-to-end um
perspective
so counselor king does that answer your
concerns about
um uh invoices and deliveries and
very simply customer interface thanks
joe
um very simply um it's it's great to
have this illumination
of of the efforts and um i come from the
it
industry myself and i it's impressive it
really is
um the weak link is
with so many residents who aren't savvy
with online portals they only use them
once a year to pay the direct debit etc
so i think there's an immensely
practical approach that i've witnessed
at
edtc which whilst
flying very well with the it advances
there's also the practical angle of
coping with
the reality on the ground with so many
residents and
so myself concluded that my tax return
once a year it's a it's a nightmare for
several days
as i try to remember what the procedures
are and indeed sometimes they change
hence i was asking about
really the more empirical approach with
pdfs being sent by email and
just to alert people and then find an
easy way in
for them it's um i i think we're all
on board with the aspirations
of highly automated get it right first
time
enter once and use many times approach
but with so many residents the the
paper or semi paper email approach
will still prevail just to get things
done on time and to alert people
in a conventional manner that time is
for
for checking what the rent and the rates
are going to be
and to pay it so um
could i just then ask follow up to that
then is when you've been having your
discussions
lawrence with the client authorities
um has this i know this being discussed
and
is this part of um your remit
or is this somewhere outside it's
because you're outside of it is getting
our
customers um computer savvy isn't it
it's what we're talking about and
yeah i think there's been quite a number
of initiatives not necessarily driven by
strata because as i've said many times
we have limited resource but
but actually i think there has certainly
during kovid been
quite a a change in mindset from people
actually being prepared to use it to
access information but i still think
that there will be
uh you know a percentage of the
population who will still want
you know the letter to come through the
post and i think we need to be fully
aware of that
and and whilst hopefully we can address
80
maybe 90 percent of demand with i.t
there will still need to be those people
who need the comfort
of being able to make a phone call
get a letter and it's ensuring that the
councils understand who those citizens
are
um you know that do still need the help
and that there are still those channels
so whilst i think
we would in the ideal world everything
moves online
let's not fool ourselves that we will be
missing a percentage of the population
should we assume everybody wants to deal
with
people online let's make sure those
channels of communication are still open
and i think the councils have done an
excellent job
on not only moving people online but
also supporting those
people who can't actually use the
technology so
um yeah but i i don't think we'll move
away from that for some time
okay sorry check would can i just add
uh to that okay the um all of the forms
that
we we publish online are also um usable
me
in a mediated manner so customer
services staff can actually use those
and fill those forms on behalf of the
customer
so where a customer can't complete a
process themselves if they do phone in
and they do speak to an advisor
the advisor just types in the
information and is more of a question
and answer type
type scenario and we are looking at
things like e-billing
with council tax so that a a pdf copy of
the bill
is sent out as part of the process and
we also
work with a company called cinetec who
are a male fulfillment company
so we'll send them the information
electronically and then they will then
send the physical hard copy of that of
that particular letter
to the resident so we still um we
we've got a variety of different means
to and
basically ensure that nobody is left um
bereft of
a service there's always a way of being
able to access that service
but we try and do for each one of those
channels in the most efficient way
possible
thank you so um i think
that's unless anybody else's wants to
add anything
i think um uh we all we need to do now
formally as a
as a committee is to um note
um that report
is that that correct trish yes yes chair
if we could have a proposal and a second
year thank you
so well i'll propose it who would like
to second it
happened a second ago thank you
um so i'm going to ask if anybody
disagrees with that can you put your
hands up now
and not seeing anyone any abstentions
um so that's past and can i thank
members for such a um
uh interesting discussion on this
so we're moving to the next item now
which is
um the finance report um
item seven so that's over to
our financial advisor dave hodgson
thank you chair uh can you hear me okay
yeah yeah thank you so this is the
report
um roughly around november
uh 20 20 21 looking at the
the full year estimate for
strata's financial performance as a
reminder
uh strata was given around 6.6 million
to
to run the it services in 2020
and in the original business plan uh
had estimated savings of around uh
700 thousand pounds 750 000 pounds
as part of the response to the kovid 19
pandemic and its impact on the financial
position of each of the three councils
strata went away and identified a
further
320 000 of in-year
savings so uh not necessarily
permanent savings but but things that it
could stop
doing uh or put back uh to the end of
the financial year
so we're projecting a saving of around
a million pounds uh as members will
will be aware uh half a million if that
is
given back in essence upfront
through reduced contract payments by the
councils
uh and the the rest will come at year
end
i'm pleased to say at the end of
november we're still looking like
delivering
uh the 543 000 on top of that half a
million pounds
uh in fact slightly more about 30 000
pounds more
we're projecting at the moment and
that's in spite of
some of the pressures that lawrence
highlighted earlier
including the the additional staff that
have been brought into support on the
help desk
so all in all a good financial position
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you um any questions then i'm not
seeing any hands up
well well in that case that's uh i it's
very
straightforward thank you very much um
for that and um that is
some good news in where we have which we
haven't had for a long time so
thank you thank everybody thank you
everyone for
for that could we um have a proposal
sorry thank you i'll propose it
seconder if i can feel again
anyone i'm happy too
okay thank you keith um so
again anybody disagree
i'll abstain chairman chris clarence
okay
right thank you any other abstentions
and so that's that's carried then thank
you
right so we are now going to move into
the um confidential part of the meeting
so this is item 8 where we will formally
exclude the president of public uh as
part of the meeting
so um the committee is recommended to
resolve that under section
100 a brackets four of the local
government act 1972 the press and public
be excluded from the meeting
for um the next um two items
on the grounds that it involves the
likely disclosure exempt information as
defined in paragraph three
of part one of schedule 12a of the act
i'm happy to propose that do i have a
seconder
yes chairman why not let's keep the
habit up phil here again
okay all right phil and it's chair
remember old habits die hard
i'm old and i promise to mend my ways
chair
okay thanks very much um
so trish could i ask you to um so he's
pro
we need to vote on that now uh does
anybody disagree
any abstentions
so that's unanimously carried then thank
you
thanks chad i'll just um i'll stop live
streaming and